Lear
how are
you had Sun the last couple days
yeah important
okay folks uh couple of things one is
reminded next Quiz is Monday first 30
minutes of class so it'll cover
everything in packet one from where we
left off on quiz one which was in cash
flows so growth rates loose end in
valuation basic intrinsic value
mechanics
like and the third quiz is going to be
two weeks after that so things are going
to pile up as I said on top of each
other I've had about 50 of your DCFS
have come in so I've returned I think
everyone I got through midnight last
night so you sent it this morning you
haven't got it back you know for obvious
reasons I will get it back to you soon
so if you get done you don't have to
wait till the Friday 5:00 deadline for
God's sakes because I don't want 300 or
500 spreadsheet showing up at that time
if you can get it to me earlier I can
get it back back to you sooner as
well and finally on the online exam I'm
still working on the actual final
Logistics but if you have to make plans
to fly out in the previous week you can
you you're welcome to do so if you have
plans with family for the last week
that's okay as well because you know we
will it you will not have to physically
be here to do the exam on the 14th which
I think which was my original objective
because that was just way too late in
the
process so let's uh let's pick up you
know on the on this on what we're going
to start today which is pricing we kind
of led into it at the end of the last
session so the start of the class test
today I want to offer a few things about
pricing that are going to
frame the session
today first one of the things I'm going
to talk about is the fact that much of
what you see out there equity research
banking is pricing not valuable
pricing is the name of the game we live
in a pricing world and the sooner we
accept that the healthier the discussion
becomes and if you ask most equity
research analysts why they use a
multiple EB debbit price earnings to put
a number on a company the answer they
will usually give you is in discounted
cash flow valuation you have to make all
these
assumptions but cash flows and growth
and risk and they don't want to make
those
assumptions do you have to make a lot of
assumptions in your DCF
valuation so that's technically true
right so they're saying they want to use
a multiple because they don't have to
make the assumptions about cash flows
growth and
risk but is that really true though when
you use a multiple are you making
assumptions R about cash flows growth
let's say I use 50 times earnings am I
making assumptions about
growth what kind of assumption am I
making high growth low growth
50 50 times 5 Z 50 times earnings I'm
assuming high growth I'm probably making
assumptions about risk as well that's
not much risk there and maybe even about
the quality of growth in other words
every single input you're running away
from is embedded in your multiple so one
of the things we're going to do as we go
through pricing is take each multiple
and kind of deconstruct it and figure
out a way to actually back out what
those implicit assumptions are cuz it's
dangerous to leave them implicit because
then you don't know what you're assuming
when you pay 100 times earnings for
palent might as well be aware of
it so let's let's focus on another
thing reason it's not
working another thing you will hear
people say right let's assume I compu
the p ratio for every company in the
market and I will today I will give you
and I put it in a distribution
can that p ratio ever be distributed
normally why or why
not this is like a Statistics test right
you said the why why
not has a tendency we tend to
overestimate not values
price it be on the right side yeah
before we do that first what what are
the requirements for normal distribution
go back to there symmetric right second
what do the taals look like on a normal
distribu tion minus infinity to plus
infinity right at least in theory what's
the lowest value p ratio can
have zero it can't drop below zero if
you have negative earnings P ratios
become not meaningful what's the highest
value who knows 10,000 50,000
150,000 it's a skewed distribut saying
who cares it's going to affect how we
think about statistics average as
opposed to medians so one of the things
we're going to talk about is the
distributional characteristics of
pricing multiples and how they play out
in how to decide whether something is
cheaper expensive so let's start on
packet two if you didn't bring packet
two with you don't worry it's not a big
deal you can pull it up after this class
or download it after the
class and talk a little bit about
pricing let's step back what is pricing
pricing you put a number on an asset
based on what other people are paying
for similar assets I mean this is a
mindset shift I want because up till now
in intrinsic valuation understand the
business understand the company figure
out what you pay for the company given
its cash flows I saying forget what that
is put a number on something based on
what other people are paying for so to
do pricing there are three things you
need to do generically first you need to
find other things just like your thing
right comparable assets pure
group so if I want to buy a ticket in
section 2 10 of Yankee Stadium I go on
StubHub and I look for other tickets and
see in that section and see what people
are charging and I pay what they're
paying
roughly if I want to buy a property I
look for other properties like it see
what people are paying for those
properties adjust for the fact that my
my property might be smaller or larger
and we talk about that adjustment and
decide what to pay based on what other
people are paying for properties and
when I'm doing when I'm looking at
attaching a number to a stock do I do I
find other companies just like mine and
already you can see this is going to be
a much tougher challenge in finding
seats in Yankee Stadium or properties
because I want to find companies just
like Microsoft how am I going to do that
I'm going to stretch the definition of
comparable to get them
there so that's the first step finding
other assets just like M second stop I
want to make sure I can compare the
prices across assets if I have houses of
roughly the same size I can compare the
price across houses right but let's say
I'm comparing two Office Buildings one
is 10 floors and the other is 60 floors
I can't compare the prices of the
buildings because those prices are not
comparable so in real estate what do we
do we divide the building price by
square footage which at price per square
foot in the context of stocks we divide
the price by something earnings Book
value a multiple is just the
standardized price and we're using a
standardized price so can compare across
companies so find comparables have a
standardized price and if you're careful
and only if you're careful you have to
stop and ask the question should I be
adjusting that pricing for the fact that
my company is higher growth lower risk
better cash flows that's the pricing
process and I'm going to start with an
assertion almost everything out there is
pricing and I'll back it up about 25
years ago I collected 550 equity
research reports from around the world
I'll confess I didn't read most of them
I collected them because I wanted to
Chronicle how sell side equity research
analyst put recommendations on stocks
the buy the sell the hold out of the 550
sells side equity research reports
45 were intrinsic valuations where a
discounted cash flow valuation drove the
buy the sell or the hold 45 less than
10%
450 were multiple and com they were
pricing he saying what about the other
55 I couldn't quite classify them they
were kind of scary so let's put them to
the side among the ones you could
categorize 10 to one pricing beats
valuation I wasn't surprised because
that's a salside equity research analyst
job right tell me what's cheap or
expensive relative to everything else
you track I said maybe it's different in
banking so I got my hands on 100
acquisition valuations and it's really
tough to do that because Bank because
when they value companies and
Acquisitions put the valuations under
lock and key and make sure nobody ever
sees them again cuz then nobody can know
can say your Synergy numbers were just
made up but I have my sources I got my
100 acquisition valuations took a look
and First Site it looked like an even
break 50/50 and then I took a closer
look at the banking DCFS and I realized
there were pricing in
drag why because the biggest number in
the DCF is the terminal value what we
say about how Bankers often estimate
terminal value they use a multiple so
even in Acquisitions pricing seems true
the day every rule of THM you run into
an investing is based on a
multiple a stock that trades at less
than a Price to Book ratio less than one
is cheap a PEG ratio less than one is
cheap a PE ratio less than 10 is cheap I
don't know where they make up these
numbers but it's based on a
multiple and that led to some soul
searching because at the end of this
class I'm going to do a
survey don't worry it's no grade won't
depend on it say and by that time you'd
have done a pricing for your company you
finished with the DCF I'll ask you to do
a pricing much less involved the end of
the class I'm going to ask you given
that you've attached a number to your
company using a DCF and a pricing which
one do you feel more comfortable using
as the basis for your decision
making
70210 every semester asked this question
that's a breakdown 70% say discounted
cash flow valuation reflecting my biases
I guess 20% say pricing was much cleaner
much more honest this DCF stuff we were
dancing around
assumptions and the 10% become Believers
in efficient markets after they valued
one company because you realiz this is a
really tough thing to do might as well
let the market do it healthy recognition
70210 I haven't done a followup survey
five or 10 years later but I'll wager if
I track people who leave this class who
go into valuation jobs and five or 10
years later I show up and say hey what
are you using on your jobs I'll wait
till the numbers get flipped it's 70%
pricing 20% valuation 10% are still
Believers in efficient
markets so I always wonder what is it
that happens between the time you guys
leave here and what happens in the death
that takes you from being true believers
in intrinsic valuation at least your
confession at the time you leave the
class to becoming Believers and pricing
I've come up with at least three you're
welcome to add to this list the first
came to me while I was watching a
Seinfeld
episode if you never watched the
Seinfeld episode The Next part will make
no sense to you but can I hang in there
anyway Seinfeld's quintessential New
York C CL in this episode one of Jerry's
girlfriends accuses him of being crazy
Jerry you're crazy
and his response is if you think I'm
crazy you should see the guy who lives
across the hall from me you know who
lives across the hall from Jerry
right coso Kramer and relative Kramer
who's crazy right you think what's this
got to do with pricing we forget how
much of valuation and pricing is selling
stuff it's easier to sell stuff based on
a pricing than it is to sell stuff based
in a
DCF so I could try to sell you on
investing in Marcado Libra and say you
know I've used a revenue growth rate of
25% for the next 5 years and then I
lowered the growth rate to 3% and I
increase their margins over time four
minutes in you've hung up the phone and
moved on who has the time for this crap
right instead if I told you Marcato lib
looks cheap because it trades at 11
times earnings and these 15 other
companies trade at 20 times earnings not
the most sophisticated sales pitch but
as long as you let me pick the multiple
in you let me pick what to compare it to
I can tell you just about anything it's
easier to sell with a price than a DCF
it's easier to defend a price than it is
to defend a
DCF I didn't do this when you send me a
DCF but I could have nitpicked every
single number right your cost of capital
that looks a little off maybe your beta
should be different your margins look
like they're too high your growth rate
should be a little lower every single
input is out there for people to pick
apart you got to defend
everything but if I told you that I put
a number on a company based on using
eight times AB da because that's what
other companies in the sector trade at
look at how small your target is you
don't like eight times AB da take it up
with the market in pricing that's my a
response it's not my fault I am just a
messenger it's an AI company 40 times
revenues you don't like to pay that's
what everybody else is
paying it's easier to defend a pricing
than it is to defend a
DCF and finally and this is a reality
check I am a True Believer in intrinsic
valuation but I'm also a realist to me
the definition of success in intrinsic
value is if I can be right 57 times out
of 100 I'm winning this game so I think
I can get up there and I think even with
good pricing I might get to 52 or 53
times out of 100 57 beats 53 right
but here's the catch when you're wrong
with intrinsic valuation you're far more
likely to be wrong alone and think of
why in intrinsic valuation when do you
tend to buy
things
Michael when or when other people give
up on them right you're more likely to
buy Tesla now than at right after the
election because everybody's giving up
on it you're often swimming against the
tide and if you're wrong everybody
notices
unfortunately not only they notice they
often fire you it's a survival mechanism
if you price things you will always have
lots of company when things go
wrong I think that drives it's a big
factor in why you end up becoming a
pricer rather than be staying with
intrinsic valuation is the penalty to
being wrong is just too
much so when I first started teaching
this class I used to try to convince
people to do valuation rather than
pricing I no longer do that because most
of you are going to end up in pricing
jobs so I've taken it as what I need to
do is to make us you know talk about how
to do pricing better rather than talking
about valuation versus
pricing so to set that process up let's
talk about what we're doing in pricing
pricing if you look at what drives it
you're reflecting the market mood in
your numbers right good or bad it shows
up in numbers
is that a good thing it depends on your
job your job is to sell a security in an
IPO you got to price the thing not value
because you got to get this the deal
done if you're investing based on
momentum you're
pricing there's a reason both in active
investing and in equity research that
pricing WIS up the second advantage of
pricing we talked about this earlier is
you always find a significant portion of
the market to be underpriced priced no
matter how high the market is because
pricing is
relative the Indian market I think is
the most overpriced Market in the world
on an intrinsic value basis but if
you're pricing in India and that's your
job as a cide equity research analyst
you will still find half of all Indian
stocks cheap on a pricing basis because
you're comparing them to other stocks in
India and if your job is to be an equity
mutual fund manager that's basically the
only way you survive and finally as a
mutual fund man in particular you get
Jud judged against what other mutual
fund managers playing the same
game there should be no surprise that
pricing ends up dominating this this
conversation so let's set up pricing in
the context of companies and
acity when you look at multiples which I
said were standardized prices let's
break out the numerator in the
denominator in the numerator you will
usually have a market Val let me take
the usually out you should should have a
market number that market number can be
the market value of equity market cap
share price times number of shares that
can be one choice it can be the market
value of equity plus market value of
debt though you might cheat and use Book
value of debt because you a market value
St have to get that's market value of
the firm or you can take market value of
equity plus debt minus cash which is
Enterprise Value market number in the
numerator the denominator is a scalar
you scale that market number to
something you could scale the market
value to revenues why might you do
that
desperation right you keep looking for a
positive number you keep climbing the
income St finally find when it's at the
top of the income statement in many
money losing sectors you have no choice
but to focus on revenues what if your
company's pre-
Revenue then you look for something that
might lead to revenues like what number
of users number of subscribers number of
cars in the parking lot these are
desperate you need something positive in
the denominator you hope that that will
translate revenues in the future so you
can trans your scalar can be a revenue
or a revenue driver it can be earnings
earnings can be just to equity investors
net income or earnings per share or to
the entire firm which can be operating
income earnings before interest in taxes
it can be to cash flows
if you being if you're know doing things
in a hurry and you don't want to get too
complex you take net income you add back
depreciation you have a rough measure of
cash flow Equity REITs and real estate
companies often use this as the measure
of equity cash flows you saying but it's
incomplete I agree in pricing the rules
from intrinsic value don't apply if you
want to do it intrinsic value in the way
we do it in intrinsic value you take net
income you add depreciation you subtract
capex you subtract change in working
Capital you subtract debt inflows and
outflows your free cash
acity you can divide back cash flows to
the entire firm again using a shortcut
you take ebit you add back D you got
ebit D it's a rough measure of operating
cash flow or you want to do it right you
can do free cash flow The Firm so you
can scale it to cash
flow and finally you can scale it to
book value what is Book value measure
it's what the accountant tells you your
Equity is worth Book value of equity or
your entire firm is worth which is Book
value of equity plus book value of debt
but if you take Book value of equity
plus book value of debt minus cash it's
that invested capitally in the
denominator for returnest Capital the
book value numbers numerator is a market
value the denominator is usually some
kind of scalar so you can come up with
the standardized measure a multiple is
always a standardized price the next
time you see an unfamiliar multiple and
they are all over the place break it out
what's in the numerator what's because
that's the first step in pricing is
making sure that that
multiple is understood so I'm going to
take you through a four-step process for
analyzing any multiple any pricing and
if you follow this process you will be a
much better pric first step in the
process I'm going to start with the
multiple you gave me and asked two
questions about it is it consistently
defined for the moment let that kind of
roll around is it uniformly
estimated second stop
I'm going to play some money ball with
the data my favorite movies one of my
favorite books Money Ball of course is a
story of you know of how numbers came to
baseball because baseball is a is a
sport Billy beans you know Oakland A's
manager had a small budget and he
discovered that these Couts who claim to
know a lot of things were just making up
stuff so after a while he said why am I
trusting this guy to tell me who the
next great pitcher is I'm going to hire
somebody to look through the numbers
baseball is the most numerical of all
sports everything is recorded and if I
want to know how many people get on base
or how often they get on base I'm going
to let the numbers drive it so I'm going
to place a money ball with the data
because there a lot of rules of thumb a
lot of in Scouts around in investing
saying a p ratio less than 10 is C let
the data tell us the second stop I'm
going to let the data tell me what to do
third stop I'm going to argue that
embedded in every multiple are
assumptions about cash flows growth and
risk but I'm actually going to make it
explicit you tell me what the multiple
you're looking at is I'll tell you what
variables drive that multiple why does
it help because then you can control for
those variables you can ask questions
about the variables so that step is
analyze the mul Define describe analyze
and only then am I going to apply and we
talk about apply I want to confront the
question what's a pure group how big
should it be can I compare a company to
the entire Market
Define describe analyze apply let's
start with the first step in the
process first thing to do when you look
at a multiple is ask yourself is it
consistently
defined me explain remember I said a
multiple is a numerated and a
denominator if your numerator is an
equity value your denominator should be
an equity value as
well if your numerator is a firm or an
Enterprise Value your denominator has to
be a firm or an Enterprise Value as well
I know it sounds abstract but I'm going
to throw a few multiples at you and you
tell me whether they pass the
consistency test let's start with PE
ratios most widely used multiple in the
world dixa what's in the numerator PE
ratio Equity value firm value Enterprise
Value Equity value right price per share
market capap and in the denominator you
have earnings per share No which is equ
thank God for small blessings most
widely used multiple in the world passes
the
test Jacob what about e what's in the
numerator which
is market value of the operating assets
of the company right technically that's
what it's supposed to measure in the
denominator of Abida rough measure of
operating cash flow so e to Abida is
okay what about price to
Abida the analyst invented this multiple
should be tarred feathered and driven
out of the fraternity right
out of the 550 equity research reports
seven used pric to have it one of them
happened to be somebody had gone through
this class A few years before so I
called the guy and I said remember that
valuation class you took a few years ago
he said
vaguely I said it shows right I said
what the heck are you doing dividing
market value of equity by Abida it's not
consistent you know what his response
was no no I'm being consistent I said
what do you mean you're consistent he
said I use price to Abida for all 15
companies in my
sector so I asked him a question I said
have you been noticing that companies
with a lot of debt keep looking cheap to
you he said yes yes I've been noticing
that I said have you ever stopped and
thought about why that might be
happening do you see how using market
value Equity divid by Abid is going to
bias you towards finding levered
companies to be cheap because what's in
the numerator the market value of equity
so if I borrow money and buy back stock
and reduce My
Equity my numerator is going to go down
but my denominator is earnings before
interest tax I can borrow money to the
cow's come home and my e do still going
to be you know what when you look at
lbos right after the
lbo and you do price to Abid you're
going to get numbers less than one it's
going to look incredibly cheap it's not
cheap it's just that you you're not
being
consistent before you feel too Superior
to this guy though if you've used price
to
sales you've been guilty of the same
sin cuz what's in the numerator market
value of equity what's in the
denominated revenues revenues don't
belong to equity investors they for the
entire firm so why do you think and I've
seen analysts use this the entire
sectors where price to sales get gets
used how do you think analysts get away
with it if it's
inconsistent yes Michael like we were
saying earlier maybe if it's the only
thing you can use well the I I have no
problem using the sales in the
denominator I'm saying why aren't you
using Enterprise Value in the numerator
because that would be the consistent
definition right so the revenue multiply
get but it should be EV to sales so how
do you think they get away using price
to sales why don't they run the same
problem as this guy with highly levered
companies
yes say usually for
for techn not even startup technology
companies basically these are and
usually how much debt do they have often
very little debt it's purely
accidental but they're okay because they
happen to pick a sector where there
isn't much debt God help them if these
companies actually start to borrow money
or start to hold a lot of cash either
scenario you're going to run the problem
it's always better to use EV to sales
but people are called a price to sales
is much more widely used so is it
consistently defined we'll do more
definitional test because I think it's a
critical part of making sure it's like
kicking the tires on your car I don't
know whe the people still do that maybe
not not a good idea anymore with the new
cars you'll talk back to you say stop
kicking me no but it it's you want to
make sure your multiple is okay before
you start to run with it and start to
use second stop is it uniformly
estimated what am I doing with this p
ratio that I'm Computing for companies
I'm doing it for 15 companies and I'm
comparing them right to do that the
earnings per share has to be computed
the same way at all 15 companies say
what's the big deal we're all covered by
Gap or
IFRS until the '90s I used to think that
was it now we're all using the same
rules but then we discovered that you
could have the same set of accounting
rules and different degrees of fidelity
to those rules what does that mean
aggressive companies without breaking
the rules can report higher earnings
conservative companies can report lower
earnings because there are discretion
that accounting gives you on some items
and they're using the discretion to kind
of push up or push down ons you see if
you don't control for this the problems
you're going to run into aggressive
companies always going to look cheap to
you and conservative companies are going
to look
expensive SNP for a brief period
actually created this data set where
they took the reported earnings for
companies and converted them to more
standardized versions but looking for
items that were discretionary there was
no market for it they gave up on it but
you can see why you need more uniformity
in how you you don't care about this an
intrinsic valuation that's why an
intrinsic valuation you can say I don't
care what the accountants do I can
reverse things I can do what I want but
when you do it in pricing you got to
make sure that there is some degree of
uniform standard govering that
denominator in fact that's one reason
when you compare across countries you
know companies that are in multiple
countries people often go back to
revenues or a number further up the
income statement because revenues are
the least temperable that's even a word
of the where counting choices make less
of a difference Michael would you go as
far as like trying to remove noncore and
like non recurring yeah that's what S&P
tried to do and know they were trying to
do that and clean up but they discovered
nobody
cared so let's take some multiples and
pass them to consistency test let's
start with P
ratios what's in the numerator usually
the current price
right unless you got one of those
technical analysts gone crazy hanging
around around you know the ones like
moving averages for everything to which
my response is have you ever tried
buying a stock at a moving average price
it never works for me say use the
current price and in the denominator is
where you get all the variant you could
divide price by earnings per share in
the most recent fiscal year some of you
that's 2023 right you can divide by
earning price that's called current P
you can divide price per share by
earnings per share in the last four
quarters it's called training P price
per share by expected earnings per share
in the next four quarters that's forward
P or price per share by expected
earnings per share in the year 2029
which is really really forward perod why
would you do that again desperation you
have tracking the biotech sector every
company's losing money what do you do
you project our earnings 10 years
forward and you tell me this company
looks cheap because it's trading at 8
times 20 34 earnings you don't even know
what to do with it
but you take it because that's what they
give you you can divide by earnings per
share before extraordinary items or
after extraordinary items I've seen
earnings per share computations before
stock-based compensation after
stock-based
compensation just as an exercise pick
any heavily followed company in the
market take the price per share that's a
given and divide by different measures
you're going to get a range of numbers
for the PE Ratio 18 to 35 saying which
one should I use
depends on what you're trying to do
right if you're trying to sell me a
company which one of those do you latch
on to this company is cheap because 18
times earnings one of the funniest
things to watch is on CNBC when you get
a bullish analyst and a bearish analyst
talking about a company the same company
heavily followed company bullish
analysts consistently use forward
earnings and more forward if they want
to get more bullish because they can
make any company look cheap somebody in
CBC was telling me last week I was
listening I don't know why I was
listening to cnpc but I must have been a
moment of weakness they're talking about
how Nvidia was selling at 12 times
earnings and I said what earnings are we
looking at 20 55 earnings I mean clearly
it's not selling but to the degree that
you let people play that discretionary
game you can talk about different
numbers first step in the process is
make sure we are talking about the same
thing so you can talk about p and I'm
talking about P make sure our
definitions converge
now building on that same theme of
consistency I want to take you a second
example let's suppose you're comparing
the PE ratios across a bunch of software
companies they're all earning money you
got the PE ratios but they have some
have options some don't some have in the
money options some have out the money
options and you're trying to come up
with a consistent measure of PE to use
so you're not creating biases
so you get the price per share for every
company but how do we compute earnings
per share we take the net income and
divide by share count right I can do
price by primary earnings per share
which is by the actual share count today
I can divide price by
deluded earnings per share which is net
income divide by the total number of
shares which you are sing if all the
options get exercised or I can divide by
partially deluded earnings per share
which is only those options in the money
are counted in the Share account I'm
going to get very different PE ratios
right if I use price divided by primary
earnings per share and I'm looking
across companies which companies are
going to look cheap to me given that
some have a lot of options and some
don't Michael yeah the ones are going to
look cheaper the ones that have a lot of
stock options issued and tell me why
well because the the um denominator is
not going to account for um or actually
the numerator reflects the fact that you
have a lot of option the market knows
you have a lot of options the price goes
down and you're not counting those
shares so you're going to find every
company that has millions and millions
and millions of options outstanding to
be cheap when in fact they could be
fairly pricely even expensive if I use
priced by deluded earnings per
share who am I biasing myself
against are all companies that have a
lot of options equally scary I mean
options can be in the money they can be
out of the money right so if you have
millions of options they all deep out of
the money
options then using price to diluted
earnings per share is not quite fair
right because the market price is going
to basically reflect the fact that these
options are not
valuable in fact I'll be quite honest if
you have options outstanding any per
share even partially diluted has
problems any per share basis for PE
ratios is going to make no sense
I'll tell you what you need to do Nobody
Does this if you truly have lots of
option differences across companies
instead of using a per share number you
take the market cap of the company and
add to it the value of the options that
this company has outstanding remember
how we valued in the DCF way add that so
the total value of equity is the value
of equity in the common stock plus the
value of the option that goes in the
numerator and in the denominator you put
the net income for the company that way
you avoid p numbers you essentially end
up with something that's consistent why
don't people do it why do we use pricing
it's simpler it's easier it's quicker
you're lazier and that's work but if you
have option differences and luckily
that's becoming less of an issue as
companies switch to restricted stock you
still have that question of including
the restricted stock and I think you
should but if there are sectors where
there are big differences in options
only way to do is deal with aggregated
numbers talk about Enterprise value taba
when I started in markets in the 80s you
probably run to EV taba one out of every
50 companies people didn't do it very
use it very much today you walk into any
equity research Department anywhere in
the world one out of three equity
research reports are built around
ev2a we'll talk about good reasons and
bad reasons why ev2 is taken off but
it's here so whenever I run into an
analyst who uses evab on there quite a
few of them I ask them are very simple
question I or at least I think it's a
simple question and I almost never get
the right answer let's see if you can
give me the right answer in the
numerator what do we have market value
of equity plus debt minus
cash in the denominator of eida so
here's my question why do we net cash
out of a numerator what you want to try
why do we net cash out of the
numerator it's not an operating asset
but keep going why is that an issue why
in the market when we do p ratios we
don't net cash
out
right now we're talking what's in the
denominator e you want to make sure that
the items you count in the numerator are
also in the denominator the reason we
net cash out is because the interest
income from cash is not part of Abit and
I've opened a Pandora's Box
so not only should I be netting cash out
but if I'm doing tart Motors remember
tart Motors Tata steel Tata chemicals
all those cross Holdings and other
companies the income from those cross
Holdings are not part of e either they
show up below you know what I need to be
nting out I need to be netting out the
estimated market value you thought you
were running away from all those
problems in discounted cash flow
valuation Crossing guess what they're
chasing you
down what happens if I own 60% of
another the company M lead me through
the process when I own 60% of another
company what is the market market value
incorporate this the 60% right markets
don't consolidate they say you own 60%
we but every other number comes from
where a
Consolidated balance sheet and every
other number is a number that reflects
100% of the subsidiary right so market
value equ is the man out here it
includes only 60% everything else is
100% you know what analysts do to kind
of fix that what's missing here the 40%
that doesn't belong to you right is
there an item on the balance sheet you
can latch on
to they take the minority interest and
what am I going to do add to the
numerator Den
subtract I'm going to add it because
that way I make it all 100 again it's a
halfast way dealing with the whole
problem why because that 40% is a book
value number the minority interest
you're adding it to a market value
number you're creating a total mess but
you say what choice do I
have people think of EV debit does
simple but often when you have cross
Holdings it can be me just to compute
the forget about comparing just
Computing the number can be a mess pick
a few family group companies try it out
because then you're going to see very
quickly the process you got to go
through just to get a clean measure of
the
EV one final example and I want somebody
from Real Estate to help me out
here real estate is notorious for
bubbles and bust even more than than
equities AR boom and they bust and they
come back boom and often one of the big
questions is should I as an outside
investor should I put my money in
equities collectively as a class or real
estate which is cheaper which is more
expensive so one of the statistics that
macro housing people have developed to
measure how overpriced underpriced
housing is is take the price of a house
and divide by the rental income you can
make if you rented that house out right
now the housing price divide by net
rental income or net of what the
expenses you have to do to maintain the
house so I have a question if that is
the ratio you're looking at now housing
price to net rental
income and you're trying to compare it
to an equity analog so you can say which
one's a better investment
which of the four multiples for equities
would you pick as the direct comparison
so let's say right now housing prices
are trading at 18 times net rental
income on the property should I compare
that to PE ratios EV to sales e toit or
E
toit
Yeah interest okay that's a good
question but my numerator what did I say
I was using the housing price so if I'm
netting out interest expense already
have an inconsistency right so if
they've neted out then I'm going to add
it back so let's assume it's before
interest expenses right so just net
rental income so it's EV multiple or a
PR or so either an evit or an EV Tabit
depending on whether I'm going to add
the depreciation of the rental income or
not but if I'm using housing prices to
rental income I can't compare the PE
ratios I should be comparing to an
Enterprise Value multiple we can debate
whether there should be Revenue Abid or
Abit because it's a strange mess when
you have rental income but it should be
an EV
multiple it's actually if you put the
graph and this is an interesting way to
compare housing price over time is to
take the P the EV to ebit for for
equities and put the housing price to
rental income over time it actually Maps
out very well in terms of predicting
when housing prices have gotten a little
out of hand is when those multiples
diverge consistency is the first
St but once you've done that you got the
multiple nail down second stop as I said
is playing Money Ball in statistics
classes when you're given a lot of data
what's the first thing you do is you
compress the data with summary
statistics right the average the
standard
deviation and usually we stop that but
if you have a lot of data it's actually
also useful to visualize the data and
the simplest way of visualizing data is
with a
histogram what do you do in a histogram
you count the companies with the p ra 0
to 4 4 to 8 8 to 12 12 to 16 and you put
them in a
distribution I find that one of the most
useful exercise in pricing is actually
looking at that
distribution I'll come back to the rest
of the questions but this is what the
distribution the histogram for PE ratios
for US Stocks look like at the start of
2025 I've done this every year for 30
years now but I take every US Stock I
take the market price I divide by
earnings per share come up with the
actually I take the market and divide by
net income cuz I don't trust the per
share numbers and capital like you I
have no idea what they count in the
share count market cap divide by net
income I get the P ratios there are
three variants that I've reported in
this graph a current P which is p price
because i'm doing this in January 1st of
2025 current p is usually 2023 earnings
trailing PE which is the four quarter is
ending through probably September 30th
of
2024 and forward P which is the
forecasted earnings per share for
2025 all three are in here and and you
can already see what we talked about at
the start of the class it's not going to
be normally distributed I didn't expect
it to the peak is to the
left it's flowed at
zero and in fact I made the tail less no
less visible than it will actually be
but counting all the companies P ratios
greater than 100 putting them in one
pile if I let the tail run out the tail
would be a long long tail
your first reaction is what difference
does it make I don't know about you but
I remember in my first statistics class
my professor saying if you have an
asymmetric distribution or a skewed
distribution he said don't trust the
average you see why if all your outliers
are big positive numbers and you have no
big negative outliers almost by
definition your average is going to get
pulled out by those big positive
outliers an average PE for stock is
almost a meaningless statistic but think
of how often you hear that number thrown
on average p in fact to show you how
meaningless it is I computed the average
P for US stocks at the start of
2025 it was 57.11067
all US Stocks Trad PE ratio less than
18 half traded at more than 18 actually
that is not technically
true because remember started with 6,062
companies in my sample only
2,67 made it into my current P here's a
good trick question to ask know once you
you're very close to point where you're
going to be the one
torturing other people by asking them
interview questions
what's the median PE ratio for US
Stocks all US
Stocks there 662 3,600 of them have
negative
earnings it's actually not available
right basically it's only among stocks
that have earnings at the median p is 18
3600 out of the 6,200 US stocks at the
start of 2025 or money losing that
statistics has remained pretty much the
same all the way through about 60% of US
Stocks consistently are money losers you
already you're saying what's the big
deal I still have a big sample
2600 but is there bias in your sample
you create by throwing out the 3600
money losing
companies anytime you throw out a subset
that's different from the market you are
going to create buyas money losing
companies tend to be smaller they tend
to be riskier perhaps higher growth
you're throwing out those
companies that average p is going to
reflect that bias I struggle with this
at the start of every year because one
of the things I try to do on my web page
is report the average PE for companies
by Industry Group let's say a group
right let's suppose take you go across
biot technology average P the first time
I did it long time ago was I comput the
PE ratio for biotech companies and took
the average then I realized that 80% of
my samp was being lost because of were
money losing and I said that's really
not an average for this
sector I report I can report the media
but what I but because I want to keep
all the data not throw out the companies
that are money losing here's what I do
to compute my my numbers on my web page
so when you look at the numbers of the
average P average price to book I take
the market cap of every biotech company
added all up I take the net income of
every biotech company added up as well
including the money losing companies I
divide the aggregated market cap of
companies by the aggregated net income
it's kind of a weighted average P then
because a larger comp but it also keeps
the money losing companies in the sample
because it gives you a collective sense
of what multiple of the earnings am I
making in the sector is the market
paying for it so the median PE takes
care of the the outliers and aggregated
PE takes care of the waiting large
companies might be the ones making money
I would do both I do the median P among
companies that have P ratios and
aggregated P because otherwise these
biases will come into play in fact if
you stay on this table notice as the as
I go from current to trailing to forward
P especially with forward P I lose
another 370 firms how come or 270
firms why am I losing them and I do
forward P what do I need for forward
P future earnings there's no way I'm
sitting there projecting future earnings
for 6,000 companies right so what am I
looking
for an analyst projection of earnings
which capital IQ very helpfully provides
if there are analysts tracking the
company you know what I'm losing when I
go to forward PE any company that's not
followed by equity research analys is
out of my sample again we introduce
buyers in the most subtle ways and the
choices we make people use Peg
ratios they take the PE Ratio divide by
expected earnings growth in the next 5
years you know only about third of
companies even in the US have expected
growth rate for the next 5
years you are creating bias the minute
you pick a multiple and the more
companies you lose from your sample the
more danger you're in of letting that
buyers drive your
conclusions so when you look at the the
basic the data questions you start with
the average you look at the standard
deviation but don't just stop there do a
histogram do the median check for biases
how many companies do I lose because all
of those things will play a role in
whether this is the multiple you want to
use to price companies so any questions
on U the just the B so I'm going to use
this to talk a little bit more about how
the data has helped me over time when I
first started doing this I used to do it
just for us companies not because I was
us Centric because that's all the data I
had access to in fact I used to you know
pay for a CD from value line with all
the data on us companies because we had
no access to a database in NYU and I do
the PE ratios for all us companies I'd
put this graph up and I'd end up in
Mumbai I put this graph of us companies
up there the histogram and somebody in
the audience grizzled Indian analyst in
50s or 60s put up his hand said doesn't
look anything like that in India like
anything like what he said the
distribution of P ratios for Indian
stocks don't look like that is how do
you know gut feeling and after about the
fifth or the sixth gut feeling it
doesn't look like that in our Market I
got lucky because starting in about 20
years ago I was able to access global
data so I do what I do for US Stocks now
for every publicly traded stock in the
market this is the distribution of PE
ratios for all Global equities at the
start of
2025 so first you have us and global
companies they look pretty much like
right Peak to the left tail to the right
doesn't mean that every Market is the
same and one way you can see the
contrast across markets I've broken them
down by sub region and there's my median
PE ratio in each
market what's the cheapest Market in the
world if you just look at p
ratio oh Eastern Europe and Russia don't
do anything crazy and pull all your
money out of US stocks and go there's a
reason for that right what's the reason
it's
riskier what's the highest PE ratio at
the start of 2025
and when I wrote about this people were
dumping on me how un patriotic I was
being this nothing to do with being
patriotic it is just the fact right you
have the highest median Peak and if you
gave me a surface reason for that what
would it be the IND story high growth
great things are
coming you can already see the prom
storytelling right you can you can
justify why Easter but it doesn't tell
me how cheap they should be or how
expensive India should be if you control
for the higher growth that India can
deliver would you still be willing to
pay 31 times earnings that's a question
we have to confront but you can see the
variations across
countries just looking at the date is
actually fascinating because otherwise
you get these distractions of people
telling you stories about countries and
this basically says this is what the
world looks like I actually find this
breaking down by Des the median to be
the most useful way rather than
traditional averages and standard
deviations it's breaking out what's the
distribution look
like
another and and when you do look at
differences sometimes they can reveal
other aspects of these markets are all
these are Price to Book ratio January
2025 there's the median price to book
ratio are there markets where a Price to
Book ratio of one which is the
traditional break even for cheapness
Works maybe but don't use it in Japan
because in Japan if use Price to Book of
one is cheap half the market looks cheap
so you look across markets you can see
the the variations in median price to
book ratios across markets again some of
this reflects differences in pricing
some of this also reflects differences
in accounting Japanese firm Japanese
accounting is notorious for allowing for
all kinds of provisions and balance
sheets which inflate the book value of
equity so Japanese stocks might look
cheap on a Price to Book ratio but then
once you control for accounting
differences you realize maybe they're
not that cheap to begin
with and I talked about rules of th it
over the over the decades I've sometimes
sat on panels with private Equity people
and the way they think about pricing is
about as shallow as you can get cuz
here's how they do oh stock that trade
in EB are less than sixes shap says who
I think it was invented by some drunk
Banker in the late 70s leaving yelling
out his all from this day on six times
IID cheap and then get pass through the
generations the next time you run into
somebody who says six times Abid is
cheaper PEG ratio is less than one is
cheap don't don't argue there's no point
arguing that number just look at the
data in 2010 if you told me six times I
was cheap I pull out the distribution e
tab for US stocks and say hey you know
what half of all US stocks are cheap to
you then because half of the market was
trading at less than six times
AB May would six times ABAB cheap
working maybe in a different Market at a
different
time unless you happen to be in Japan or
Russia in which case stop working
again I think we need to stop using
absolute numbers for rules of thumb
right you say as opposed to what why not
make it the 25th percentile we have the
data if your definition of cheap is it
looks cheap relative to the market it
shouldn't be defined as six or eight or
one it should be defined as let's look
at the distribution let's see what the
20th 25th percentile is so in the US a
stock that trades at less than 8.6
times now in this case EV EV in 2025
would be cheap given how everything else
was being priced in the market you
saying I don't like that hey it's
pricing take it or leave it right that's
what the market is demanding let the
Data Drive how we think about cheaper
expensive rather than some rule of thumb
that was invented probably 50 60 years
ago and passed through the
generations so that's a descriptional
test basic statistics taking looking at
the data we have no excuse not to do
this
anymore 50 years ago even 30 years ago
your excuse maybe this is a lot of work
we have to go collect the data
excuse is gone right if you use Capital
IQ in a minute you can pull up the P
ratios for every company in the
market use the
data second stop third
stop take a look at what drives each
multiple there are two basic questions I
would like to ask and answer when I look
at a multiple first is what are the
variables that drive this multiple what
are the things I need to control for and
I'm going to give you a very simple
device for backing out
given any multiple what the variables
are that determine that multiple and
second not only do I so I'll give you a
preview the p ratio is driven by three
variables just three variables the cost
of equity the expected growth in
earnings per
share and the payout ratio SL return
Equity that's it and I'll tell you why
how I came up with the three variables
but then I have to also tell you how as
each of those variables changes my p
ratio will change let's say at least
take the intuition as growth goes up
what should usually happen to P ratios
holding all its
constant p ratio should go up as risk
goes up p ratio should go down as return
of equity goes up p ratio should go up
but I need to be more explicit by how
much will it go up if my growth
doubles so let's let me go through the
device I find useful for backing out
what Drive the
m so let's start with the multi price
that's what you use because that's what
you like using you come to me and say
what are the variables that drive to
drive Price to Book price to book Equity
multiple or Enterprise Value
multiple Price to Book is usually price
per share Book value of equity per share
it's an equity multiple because it's an
equity multiple I'm going to go back to
the simplest Equity valuation model
discounted cash flow model that I can
think of in my from my perspective
that's going to be a stable growth
dividend discount model right don't have
high growth periods in a stable growth
dividend discount model the value of a
stock should be the expected dividend
next year divided by cost of equity
minus growth
rate so I'm doing the terminal value
calculation right away with expected
divage there's the equation that's the
stable growth that's a garden growth
model oldest discounted C am I allowed
in an equ in algebra to divide both
sides of the equation by a constant yeah
it should so what if I divide both sides
of the equation by the book value so
left hand side will now become The Price
to Book value so I've got the my right
hand side I will have you know net
earnings divide by book values return
and Equity times payout ratio divide by
cost of equity minus the growth rate
saying it's an intrinsic value equation
you're saying we're doing pricing why
are we going back to intrinsic value I
agree but it's now telling me what
variables drive a Price to Book ratio
it's cost of equity growth rate payout
ratio and return Equity any Equity
multiple go back to stable dividend
discount model make sure your algebra is
not too rusty but if you follow the
algebra you can take any Equity multiple
and state it in terms of a dividend
discount let's say you want to do EV to
sales it's an Enterprise Value multiple
the simplest Enterprise value equation I
can think of is a stable growth firm
where I take the expected free cash FL
of the firm next year and divide by cost
to minus the growth
rate again I divide both sides by sales
if I divide ebit * 1us T divide by sales
I get after tax operating margin so I've
converted the the drivers of an EV to
sales ratio the after tax margin the
reinvestment rate the cost of capital
and the growth rate the same assumptions
You' have had to make in DCF now show up
as drivers of the
M for the moment you might say how does
this help us I'm going to take you
through a series of examples where we
will play with those that the knowing
what those variables are because that's
what's going to allow us to
control so if you want to take a closer
look at why I told you P ratios d by
payout ratio cost of equity and the
growth rate there's der in discount
model you divide both sides by earnings
per share you get p ratio on the left
hand side dividends divide by earnings
per share gives you payout ratio there's
a 1 plus G if you're using last year's
dividend if you're using next year the 1
plus G will disappear and in the
denominator of cost of equity minus the
growth
rate you're saying what if I don't trust
dividends we we said company you can
replace dividends with a free cash
Equity ultimately you go back to
Intrinsic valuation because it'll allow
you to ask the right questions when
somebody's trying to sell you something
using a
multiple you ready I'm going to I'm
going to be the the the person trying to
sell you something and you you get a
chance to ask me questions to make sure
that I that I'm not selling you
something that looks cheap but is
actually not
cheap stock trades at half a book value
that's my entire P therefore it's cheap
Michael ask me the questions about the
company it will allow you to determine
whether half of Book value is
to it's my expected growth rate 50% of
the time what's your answer going to be
it's shrinking you hang up the phone
you're done right let's say my growth
rate is a reason number 3% 4% 5% what's
the next question yeah what is your cost
or how cost of equity right remember we
follow the same rules Equity multiple
and it might be a cost so you know it
might be that I have some risk it could
be in the cost of equity it could also
be other risks right so distress risk
failure risk questions about risk 25% of
the time half of Price to Book when
you're trading at half a book value
you're probably a very risky company
hang up the phone again let's say I make
through that second screen my growth is
not an unreasonable number my risk is
not too high third
question repaying out all your pre tax
or you can reframe it right when I grow
I have to reinvest and I reinvested a
return Equity what's my return
Equity most of the time the answer is I
earn 3% return Equity there's your
answer that's why I traded half a book
value my definition of a cheap stock on
a pricing basis is a mismatch you know
what I mean by a mismatch you want to
look PE ratio a low price to book ratio
but you want a low growth rate or a high
growth rate for that
mismatch you want a high growth rate
you're going to catching on low return
Equity High return Equity you want a
high return Equity you want low risk you
saying what chance are finding something
like this no harm
looking you're looking for things that
look cheap but have no good reasons for
being cheap and what this allows you to
do is ask what are those questions I
would ask that person low even Tabit low
EV sales you now have the variables you
need to focus
on now this equation looks intimidating
but it's actually a present value
equation it's a stable growth dividend
discount model right it works fine if
you have a mature company saying what if
I have a high Growth Company how would I
ask this question for NVIDIA well
clearly there's high growth in the near
term I'm going to stay with the dividend
discount model but I'm going to make it
a two-stage dividend discount model see
this first term in the equation that's a
present value of a growing annuity those
are the dividends during the high growth
phase the second term even though it
looks unfamiliar is the present value of
the terminal price so I've just
basically taken what we have in a
spreadsheet and written it out as an
equation when I wrote my first edition
my valuation textbook is reviewed by
somebody in baren and they said I like
the book but it's full of obscure
mathematical equations and was talking
about this one we're in deep trouble
when present value equations have become
obscure mathematical equations but this
is what we Harvest when we put a PV
button on a calculator I'll wag of most
of you don't remember the the annuity
equation anymore why would you need to
payment present value but these are just
present value equations the value of a
stock is the present value of the
dividend during the high growth phase
there a present value deter that what's
the PE ratio for a high Growth Company
divide both sides of the equation by
earnings per share and Magic happens it
turns out the p ratio for a high growth
company is a function of three variables
it's cost of equity its growth rate and
its payout ratio the only difference is
you have to estimate them twice once for
the high growth phase and once for the
stable growth
phase this is amazingly good news right
especially your algebra is Rusty why
because for any multiple then even if
it's a high growth company to find the
variables that that you need to control
for you can just stay with the stable
growth Model come up with the variables
and know that you've got to estimate
them multiple times you have multiple
stages of growth I'm going to use this
kind of with a very simplistic example
to kind of extract the maximum that I
can out of that very simplistic equation
so let's say I come to you with a high
growth F it's got a 15% expected growth
rate for the next 5 years and 1.5%
thereafter
it's got a 25% payout ratio for the next
5 years why does the payout ratio low
because I need to grow I need to
reinvest and in 92 a half% payout ratio
of D5 why so high because my growth rate
has dropped 1 and a half per. my Beta
let's for the moment at least leave it
at one I could have made a change high
in the high but let's leave it at one
it's an average risk company and let's
assume that the t- bond rate is 1 and a
half% the equity risk premium is 5% I'm
going to try to compute an intrinsic p
ratio for this company it's kind of a
pointless exercise I'll tell you why in
a moment but let's compute an intrinsic
PE ratio so I go back to the equation I
plug in the 25% payout ratio for the
high growth period 15% growth rate and
65% cost of equ that's my high growth
period dividends and that is my terminal
value 92 and half% pay so basically if
you did this on a spreadsheet You' get
the
same my intrinsic PE ratio for this
company is
29.1549
one5 times earnings why are you paying
29 .5 times earnings because it's a high
growth company right what's your
nightmare scenario when you invest in a
high growth
company that you wake up one day and you
discover there's no
growth just
surprised could you get a positive
surprise yeah it could be higher than so
this 15% growth is what you expect but
it could be 20 it could be five it could
be seven we know the direction if the
growth is less than expected the PE
Ratio is going to decrease the growth is
greater than expected the p ratio will
go up nice thing about doing a
hypothetical example is I kept
everything else constant and changed
just the growth rate in the first five
years so everything else in the process
stays the same so I've tried growth
rates from 0 to 30% so 0 to 15 are the
negative surprises 15 to 30 are the
positive
surprises I've also listed at four
different different risk R rates we'll
talk about how that plays into but every
level of of interest rates as my growth
goes up my PE ratio goes up right so no
surprise but here's what I want you to
focus on as risk free rates change from
0 to 6% the effect of changing growth
becomes smaller and smaller
right why is that why is my PE ratio
changing by less when I have a 6% risk-
free rate in fact if I put 10% 20% the
effect get smaller and smaller as my
risk rates go up why is the effect of
changing interest rates
know laage almost what's the value of
growth it's all in the future right as I
raise my risk- free rate what am I doing
I'm making the present value of growth
less and less in fact let's say make
this
Venezuela let's say your risk free rate
is 5,000% what's the value of
growth zero what if I surprise you and
give you more growth than expected it's
still zero what if I surpris you deliver
less growth than expected you don't care
when growth rates become really when
risk free rates become really high
growth becomes a less and less critical
part of value one of the problems
investors faced in the last decade when
rates became historically low is the
growth part of value became a much
bigger percentage of value for every
single company and it's by definition
much more
volatile cuz what's the form in in which
you get this news that your growth
company is no longer going to be a
growth company is it an angel in the
middle of the night no it's usually an
earning report right you wake up to oh
my God I thought you were growing 20%
but you seem to have lost to zero you're
growing at only
2% you know how this plays out when you
have an earning surprise then and
interest rates are low the effect of a
given earning surprise is going to be
much greater under low interest rates
than under high interest rates even
though surprise looks the same because
the effect on the value of your growth
is so much greater when risk free rates
are 1 and a half% than when there's
6% I also looked at what would happen
because I remember the beta used was one
so what would happen if my Beta was 0.5
or two or 2.5 again no surprise in terms
of direction for any given growth rate
as I increase risk my PE ratios decrease
I've looked at now for you know
different growth rates 5 10 15 20 but
every single growth rate higher the risk
the less value you're saying so what
let's say you're a
company that has a beta one and a p
ratio and and a growth rate of 15% so
they're 29.1549
by reducing risk
right which one's better it depends on
where you are in the life cycle there
will be a point in every growth
company's life cycle where the payoff to
reducing risk is going to be greater
than the payoff to increasing growth but
they won't even notice because they're
so focused on let's go for that extra 3%
of growth the extra 5% that they
miss both increasing growth and reducing
risk increase my increase your P which
one's better for you will depend depend
on who you are as a company and again
it's just a pure math playing out in
both directions in fact I've listed out
what I call a superstar Superstars are
companies which have low risk and high
growth investment dogs are the companies
the exact opposite and it might be
useful to take a market and break it out
where in the market are all the
companies that I have in the
index one final example know embedded in
this example are assumptions about the
quality of growth which you didn't see
because I use payout ratio as my measure
but remember payout ratio times know
with return Equity that conjunction is
what delivers growth so what I've done
in this table is taken the return and
equity and Investments and the expected
growth rate for the next 5 years and
estimated what the PE Ratio will be for
this
company for different returns and Equity
so as my returns and Equity go from 5 to
25% my PE ratio
increases but if I focus just on the 5%
return Equity company and it goes for
more and more growth look at what
happens to its p
ratio it goes very quickly toward zero
growth by itself is what not what pushes
up your P rati it's growth with a return
Equity that is higher than the cost of
equ that's why we need all four
questions right you can't just stop
what's your growth rate because I could
give you a massive growth rate but if
that growth is coming with a terrible
return Equity I deserve to trade at a
low PE ratio
so I know it's a simplistic hypothetical
example but we're going to use what
we've learned from that and here's what
I'm going to do I'm going to play the
role of a naive analyst and I'm going to
put recommendations in front of you and
by now you have the ammunition to shoot
me down I want you to shoot me down with
each of these examples by telling me
what I might be
missing so here's my first thing start
at
2024 I pulled up the the E tab it done
the trading PE for a bunch of Emerging
Markets
Zombia the cheapest Market 3.7 75 times
I 4.31 times
earnings looks incredibly cheap on an
earnings basis
right but you can also see that the
markets are not just risky there are
variations risk even across these
markets so if you if I try to push you
to the lowest P it's a riskiest market
so I'm going to talk about a way in
which you might be able to control for
these differences when you look at
across country and this is a very old
example but you can update it using
today's data a bunch of markets June of
2000 you know emerging developed
slightly developed fully developed
there's a PE ratio across the markets if
I pick purely based in PE ratio the
cheapest Market in the world in 2000 was
Turkey 12 times
earnings but I've also added three other
variables that I wanted to think about
when you think about the combination you
want in a cheap Market I've added
interest rates if you're an investor do
you want low interest rates or high
interest
rates you probably want lower interest
rates to go I've added real growth in
the economy you want High real growth or
low real growth you want High real
growth and then I've added a country
risk
measure you want Low Country risk High
real growth low interest rates and a low
PE ratio right and if you just sit there
you know eyeballing the data you're
going to get dizzy after a while right
it's only so much you can do this is
where you pull your statistics textbook
out of the
recycling your recycling hasn't been
emptied for 7 years or 10 years or go to
a store and buy back the book is sold
back because remember that chapter in
multiple
regressions what are you do in a
multiple regression you got a dependent
variable that you're trying to explain
and you have a bunch of variables that
you think will help you explain that
dependent variable what's the dependent
variable here what are you trying to
explain ratios across companies what are
the three things you wor about growth
interest rates and
risk there are probably statistical
issues with this regression but I ran a
regression anyway there's a p ratio for
the sample that you saw against the
level of interest rates the growth in
GDP and the country
risk and the signs at least are in the
right direction that the data doesn't
always have to do what you'd like it to
do what do I mean by the right
directions higher interest rates
translate into lower PE ratios higher
real growth in GDP translates into
higher PE ratios and higher country risk
translates into a lower PE
ratio of course I should have reported
the T statistics so you can see if
they're statistically significant you
got to take my word they were
statistically
significant the r squ was about 73% I'm
not going to get too car it's a small
sample all you need is a couple of but
it's a it's a decent R squ you saying
I'd like a 100% R squ won't we all right
but remember when you ask what's a good
R squ that's really the wrong question
low R square just means it's a bigger
forecast error on the forecast you get
out of the regression now what was my
the reason I did this I wanted to see
which of those markets was truly cheap
right was Turkey actually cheap is there
a way I can use this
regression to answer the question
whether turkey is really cheap let me
show you the turkey Market there what do
I need to
do take the interest rates for turkey
the GDP real growth for Turkey the
country risk for turkey plug it into the
regression I'll get a predicted ping
what does that tell me given the growth
the risk and interest rates in Turkey to
tell me this is what you it's still
priceing but it's control pricing so I
did that for turkey I got a predicted PE
of
13.35 it's undervalued but ever so
mildly in fact I've taken every country
in my sample plug the numbers in the
regression got a predicted PE for let's
say you're you're you're a global
investor and you want to decide which
markets of the world to go into you
don't want to end up in Eastern Europe
you don't want to avoid India one way to
bring growth and risk and you know
interest rates in is to add them to
those remember those regions you could
add them on and say after controlling
for growth risk and return equity which
of these parts of the world they want
want to be it so again this is data you
can it's relatively easy you get your
hands on now you can download the data
across countries and see if you can
start explaining why different countries
trade at different
multiples talk about us stocks
everybody's favorite metric is p ratio
right fact half of the bubble folk this
is their entire ammunition the PE ratio
for US Stocks is high therefore US
stocks are overpriced
let's start with the part of the
statement that is true are US Stocks
trading at historically high PE ratios
absolutely in fact you can see at the
start of 2025 you look at the P ratios
and I've used variance of the PE Ratio
there's there's a standard P right to
the X there's a normalized p saying
what's a normalized p you take the
average earnings over the last five or
10 years you don't get that then you
have the Shiller P which is that with an
inflation adjustment the reason you have
an inflation adjust his earnings from 5
years ago can't be compared so it's
really all first thing to recognize they
all really give you the same answer just
F it's you're just playing at the edges
But ultimately they all send the same
message start of 2025 US Stocks looked
expensive you know you can't contest
that the p ratio is refle of that but if
you think about the alternative year you
say what would I invest in if I did not
invest in stocks you could invest in
t-bonds and I've actually computed a p
ratio for t-bond you saying what does
that even mean just invert the coupon
rate right if your coupon rate is 5%
that's p ratio for a t- bond is s what
was the T bond rate just four years ago
2021 it's 2% the T bond rate for so the
P for T Bonds in 2021 was 50 no one so
I've just put that into and in the last
column I've actually computed the Shila
P divide by the t-b rate because for an
entire decade this roow may crazy people
would talk about us stock being
expensive by comparing to historical
averages and not bring in the fact that
t- Bond rates were at
2% should have finally caught on he
actually redid this but it took him a
long time to catch on as well but
basically this is PE ratios across time
so the question we're facing is given
where we are in the market today would
you pay 24 times earnings for US stocks
in the Agri so I'm going to set the
leave that gra because in the start of
next class I'm going to talk about how
we can bring cuz he said what about
interest rates what about growth what
about risk we're going to bring those in
and ask a question after we control for
difference in those can we draw a
conclusion about your talks it's a
little more nuance and just comparing P
ratios across time so I will see you on
Monday and after the quiz we will as I
said pick up on pricing and keep going
got be mytf